[MUSIC]
[APPLAUSE]
>> A quick show of hands.
How many of you remember
playing with these as kids?
Awesome.
I for one can close my eyes and reminisce
the absolute sense of imagination and
creativity that these blocks could evoke.
But imagine if you could use these
blocks to create a world of your own,
a real world.
So that could be something
like you being sent back in
time to 1624 to recreate
the city of New York.
How cool would that be?
Can you imagine the endless possibilities?
Well, that's exactly
the feeling that I got
when I looked at my job
description about six years back.
The project in this instance,
was the first of its kind,
city within a city concept in the world.
It was called
the Dubai International Financial Center.
So, as it happened,
the government of Dubai had latched
onto this opportunity that there was no
financial center which was serving
the region between London and Singapore.
Now, I probably know what some
of you are thinking here.
You're probably thinking well we know,
this region has a lot of potential.
But then, we also know that this region
is synonymous with certain other words.
Red tape, corruption, poor infrastructure,
social and political turmoil.
And you would be absolutely correct.
However, we are not today here
to talk about the present.
We are here to talk about a future,
a future in which you all
will be global leaders.
So how about we take a look at
the macroeconomic future for
this part of the world?
If we were having this conversation in
say, 2009, this region's overall economic
output would have been something around
40% of the size of the U.S. economy.
Fast forward onto 2020.
This number could be as high as 55%.
And by 2030, this number could be 70% or
even higher.
In a sense,
this region would be imperative for
your business,
no matter what business you're in.
And the cool part is that the trends
which are changing these
numbers are already underway.
About a decade back, if you were running
an international business, your business
would have been a part of what was known
as the East West Trading Corridor.
And the East West Trade Corridor
used to contribute to
about $8.5 out of every $10
exchanging hands globally.
However, in the last decade,
there is another force which is changing
the landscape of global trade completely,
and this phenomenon, ladies and
gentlemen, is known as a new Silk Route.
Let's try to understand this phenomena
through the eyes of our first protagonist,
Chun Lee.
Now, Chun Lee is a first
generation Chinese entrepreneur.
She started a small disposal medical
supplies business back in 2003.
She was catering clients to predominantly
in Europe and in the Americas.
However, as we all know,
by 2009, things had changed.
The world was different.
Poor economic conditions and
the fact that regulations had become
really stringent in the West,
forced her to consider other markets.
It was at that point in time that she
heard about this whole story of growth
in Africa, and India, and the Middle East.
Not surprisingly, 16 months later,
Chun Lee was on a plane
halfway across the globe.
And she started a very small re-export
hub in Dubai with just five employees.
In 2010, I was fortunate
enough to meet Chun Lee again.
And this time around boy,
how the fortune's changed.
Her five man operation had
grown to over 100 employees.
And her business had grown 1200%.
And let me assure you,
Chun Lee is not an exception.
In fact, according to the World Bank, this
zone, or the South South Trading corridor,
or the New Silk Route,
is gonna contribute to $7 out of every $10
exchanging hands globally by 2030.
I saw the proof of this
growth first time myself,
from the city that I was
privileged to start.
When we started in 2004, these were
the clients which were registered with us.
20 of them, and these are all of them.
I would love you to guess as to how
many clients did the city host today.
1400 plus and this is just a small
sample of the kind of clients it hosts.
But then, the business and economics
is just one part of the equation.
There is a far greater social force
which is completely transforming this
part of the world.
Now let me ask you all a question
at this point in time.
If I ask all of you which country or
region in the world today
produces the highest proportion of women
entrepreneurs, what would your answer be?
I'll bet a lot of you would
be saying Silicon Valley,
but you would be surprised if said no,
it is not Silicon Valley.
But in fact, it's in places like Yemen and
Uganda where 40% of
the entrepreneurs are women.
Let's try to understand this phenomena
through the eyes of our second
protagonist, Nigella.
Nigella is a mother of four and
she's a Saudi national.
Ever since she was 16,
she always wanted to start her own
private brand of clothing label.
Unfortunately, the society did
not give her much of a chance.
In fact, apart from a supportive husband,
nobody really came to help and added to
that, the regulations in Saudi Arabia for
women entrepreneurs was so stringent
that she was not even allowed to represent
herself in front of the government.
And in spite of all these limitations,
Nigella finally broke through the glass
ceiling and started her own private
label in 2012 and named it Sheila.
Now, having seen Nigella, and by the way,
Nigella is the one to your left.
Now, having seen Nigella and having
kinda heard her story, do you believe
you really understand the needs and
aspirations of Nigella as a customer?
And this is where most
multinationals make a mistake.
They pick up a product,
a service from one part of the world and
take it to another part without really
understanding the ground realities.
Did you really understand the trials and
tribulations of Nigella?
Do you really understand
the environment that she operates in?
It won't really justify that
Nigella gives her business to you.
So now, going back to our
example of the Lego bricks,
this region is like a pack of Lego bricks
where all the pieces are coming together.
Some of these pieces are broken,
some are not there and
there are others which
are still under formation.
And it would be your responsibility as
future leaders to put all of these pieces
together and while you do that, you need
to remember that there is no precedence,
so you need to push the status quo.
You need to be innovative, but
at the same time, you need to be patient,
and you need to be respectful.
And there are a couple of principles
which I personally like to follow,
which I would love to share with you all.
First, read, but don't always take
the mass media too seriously.
Secondly, learn, but start by unlearning.
And finally,
every opportunity that you get go out and
meet the Nigella and
the Chun Lee's of the world.
Try to soak in a little bit of
their culture and their life.
And I must admit,
I made my own fair share of mistakes.
In my first stint in the Middle East,
I was suppose to start
a woman's only banking product for
one of the multinational clients.
And I went into the market
imagining them to be my customers.
And I was not totally off the mark.
They were in fact a part of the segment
that I was going to cater to.
But I made one fundamental mistake.
I forgot the other end of the spectrum.
So let me try to end this presentation
with one of my favorite quotes.
The mind is like a parachute,
it does not work, if it doesn't open.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
[MUSIC]